محاولات اخيره اجراها الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه تيك توك شوتشي بهدف انقاذ التطبيق
من الحظر في الولايات المتحده شو هو خلال
جلسه للادلاء بشهادته امام الكونغرس شدد
ان الشركه تاخذ المخاوف الامريكيه على
محمل الجد وجدد الرئيس التنفيذي لتيك توك
بوعوده بان الشركه لن تسمح بالتلاعب
ببيانات المستخدمين من اي جهه وانهم طبعا
ملتزمون بحمايه المستخدمين الامريكيين هذا
وسع رئيس تيك توك لاقناع المشرعين بان
التطبيق الذي يضم 150 مليون مستخدم في
الولايات المتحده وحدها لا يشكل خطرا على
الامريكيين او يشارك البيانات مع الحكومه
الصينيه فلنستمع لمقاله
لدينا اكثر من مليار مستخدم بينهم 150
مليونا في امريكا وضعنا تدابير لمنع ارسال
رسائل نصيه للمستخدمين دون 16 عاما ولا
نعارض اي مساله تتعلق بالخصوصيه تم بناء
جدران حمايه للبيانات الامريكيه وباشراف
موظفين امريكيين وهم فقط من يمكنهم الوصول
للبيانات الامريكيه التي ستكون تحت رقابه
الوكالات الامنيه الامريكيه اننا ناخذ
المخاوف الاميركيه على محمل الجد ولن نسمح
بالتلاعب ببيانات المستخدمين من اي جهه
مسؤوليتنا تتمثل في حمايه المستخدمين
الامريكيين وملتزمون بذلك نحن الشركه
الوحيده التي تقدم بيانات شفافه لسنا شركه
حكوميه
من الاستثمارات اجنبيه
لكن يبدو كل هذه الوعود والمبررات لم تقنع
الكونجرس الامريكي الذي حذر من ان تيك توك
يشكل خطرا على بيانات الامريكيين ويجب ان
يتحلى بالشفافيه الكونجرس قال ايضا ان
الحزب الشيوعي الصيني قد يخترق هواتف
الامريكيين عبر هذا التطبيق وطلب الشركه
بضبط المحتوى وعدم تحوله لاداه لتجسس
[موسيقى]
ومع هذه الشهاده على وجه الخصوص من الواضح
ان يواجه معركه عبثيه وسط ترجيحات بان
المرشحين او المشرعين الرئيسيين في اللجنه
اتخذوا القرار بالفعل وفي هذا الاطار تشمل
خطه تيك توك البالغه مليار و500 مليون
دولار وضع البيانات الامريكيه في خواتم
محليه مملوكه لشركه اورك الكرب والسماح
بمراجعه خوارزميه هذه الشركه
وتوصيات تيك توك